-Our first guest tonight
is a United States Senator
from Massachusetts.
Please welcome back to the show
Senator Elizabeth Warren!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Senator.
Well, it has been -- it has been
a week of historic news.
Not all good, most bad.
But let's start
with a silver lining.
Judge Ketanji Brown-Jackson
becomes the first Black woman
on the Supreme Court.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know her other first?
She is the first public defender
to sit on the United States
Supreme Court.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Think about --
Just for one second,
think about what that means.
This is a woman who has made
public service her life
and who is so committed
to the principles of justice
that she made her work
about speaking up for people
who couldn't afford
to have lawyers,
who weren't
going to have a voice
except for someone like her
who stepped in
and said, "That's my job
and I'm going to be
part of making this
justice system work."
She's going to be fabulous
on the Supreme Court.
-That's a really interesting
point
because I think we often talk
about the hegemony of, like,
how the backgrounds and
sort of the racial backgrounds
or, you know,
the gender backgrounds --
But really that's such
a interesting point,
because everybody comes from it
from the same side of the law.
And, of course,
the law is multifaceted.
So that'll be great to have
that new perspective.
-That's right.
We have had a lot of people
who came from the side
of all those corporations
who desperately needed help.
-Yeah.
-And now
it's really terrific to have --
It's kind of amazing
it took us this long, right,
that we have
our first public defender.
She's going to be terrific.
-Unfortunately, it seems like
a lot of her role will be
to be one of 3 people
on the side of 6-3 decisions.
You know, we had another one
today about emissions.
Basically, the court ruled
that the EPA is very limited
in the sort of emissions
they can regulate
from different plants.
What are
the grander implications
of a decision like this?
-So, look,
this is a Supreme Court
that is basically
out of control.
And they have decided
that they don't like
the way that we have,
for decades now, tried
to deal with climate change.
This has been a very
pro-corporate court,
and this is actually
not the first decision
in that direction.
They've been anti-union.
They've been anti-consumer.
They've empowered corporations
more than ever before,
giving them
religious liberty rights,
letting them contribute
money, money, money
to influence
the political process.
And I see this as just --
this is one more decision
heaped on losing
Roe versus Wade,
heaped on a gun decision
that is going to make life
more dangerous
for all of our children,
for all of our neighbors,
for all of our loved ones.
It really is a time
when the American people
are losing confidence
in the Supreme Court,
and for good reason.
A court
that is not grounded in law,
not grounded in, uh...
in the principles
on which we have tried
to build a country
going forward,
but instead a court
that says, nope, they're just
going to substitute
their own personal views
and make the rest of America
bend to it.
-So this is a time
where I feel like --
You must be hearing this a lot
from your constituents,
from the people you talk to.
It seems like there's
two reactions you have,
which is to be sad
or to be angry.
Do you feel like one
is more helpful than the other?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Sad.
You got a few hours for that.
-Okay.
-I will go as much as 24.
-To 2 to 24 hours.
-And that's it. That's it.
2 to 24 hours.
And after that,
cold bucket of water.
Because now
it is time to be angry
and to channel that anger
into action.
And the reason for that is sad
is about leaning back
and giving up,
and we can't do that.
There is a path out of this.
It is not an easy path.
It is not a guaranteed win.
But I guarantee you this --
you don't get
what you don't fight for.
So it is powerfully important
to take the anger over what
the Supreme Court has done
and channel it into action.
Can we do the actions?
-Let's do the actions.
-Let's do it. Alright.
Let's do it.
Right now on Roe,
the first one is
there are people out there
right now
who are pregnant
and who need help.
They need protection.
And we need to pour resources
into helping them.
That means each of us
volunteering money,
volunteering time
to support the organizations
that are trying to help people.
The administration is stepping
in, using all of its tools.
And I commend the President
for stepping up,
for example,
on medication abortion,
making that
more widely available,
protecting people
who have to cross state lines
in order to get help.
We should be looking at the fact
that the federal government,
biggest employer
in the country --
make sure that people
have got time off from work
and resources to travel.
So we need to do things
to protect people
who are pregnant now
and who get pregnant next month
and the next month,
because this is the
urgent problem in front of us.
But second thing we need to do
is we got to focus like a laser
on the election in November.
Understand --
this small minority
that wanted to overturn Roe
has been disciplined.
They have worked at this
for nearly five decades.
They lost and they got back up
and they stayed in the fight.
And they helped
all of those senators
who help shepherd through
these justices
who swore
until the world looked level
that Roe was settled law
and that we don't disturb
settled law.
And as soon as they got
the votes, they went ahead
and did not just
to chip away at Roe --
just blew the whole thing up.
We need to be just as committed,
just as focused
on this election in November.
Two senators.
If we pick up
two Democratic senators
who will help us
get rid of the filibuster,
which the President has now said
he's on board for that,
and who will give us
Roe versus Wade --
Two senators.
And, yes, John Fetterman, I am
looking at you in Pennsylvania.
Yes, Mandela Barnes,
I'm looking at you in Wisconsin.
We get those two senators in,
we hang on to the House,
and Roe versus Wade
will be the law
all across America.
That's what we can get done.
That's a fight worth having.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think it's important --
And I appreciate the optimism.
What do you say to people
who feel as though
maybe Democratic leadership
did get caught
a little flat-footed from --
I mean, it did feel like this
was coming for 50 years.
Now, maybe nobody thought
it was going to happen.
But we've certainly known
for the last few months,
based on the leaked draft,
this was coming.
And it did seem like
it took the White House
maybe six days to come out
sort of with their plan.
Why wasn't there
a plan in place,
or was there and it was
just slow to come out?
-Look, I think what matters
is that we are using
every tool in the toolbox
and doing everything we can
to protect people
who are pregnant right now
and need help.
But understand this --
we have every single Republican
in the United States Senate
and the House
has voted against
Roe versus Wade.
We actually had this --
Nobody quite remembers this.
Just a few weeks ago,
we actually voted this
in the Senate,
and every Republican said nope
on Roe versus Wade.
You know what?
We got elections coming up.
We need to hold every Republican
accountable for those votes.
-I have a lot more to ask you.
We will be right back with more
from Senator Elizabeth Warren.